-You guys,
we are just two days away
from the official start
of summer, which means...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Which means kids are force
to take those summer jobs
nobody else wants --
pool cleaner, delivery boy
White House Press Secretary,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Trump, last nigh
was the president's
first official 2020 campaign
rally and festival,
or as his supporters were
calling it, Wallapalooza.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Trump filled u
an arena in Orlando
and gave a big speech.
He spent most of the time
bashing immigrants, journalists,
and Hillary Clinton.
Meanwhile,
everyone watching at home
was like,
"Is this a summer rerun?
[ Laughter ]
I've seen this before."
At one point, Trump asked
the crowd what they think
his 2020 campaign slogan shoul
be.
He said, round of applause
what's your favorite,
and gave them a few options.
Watch this.
-First, we do
Make America Great Again,
then we do Keep America Great.
Let me hear it. Ready?
Make America Great Again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Keep America Great.
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Trump ]
Here's a third option.
Are you ready?
Make Keeping America Great Again
Great Again.
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
-I don't know.
-[ Normal voice ]
After that, he was like,
[ As Trump ] "Okay, next poll --
who do you think will win
'The Bachelorette,'
Luke P. or Jed?"
A lot of people say Luke P
[ Laughter ]
You said Jed.
[ Normal voice ] Actually
the White House says Trump
is going to keep using the
slogan Make America Great Agai
and wearing his usual red hat.
It's like when your kid
only wants to wear
that one superhero outfit
to school, and you're like
"Whatever gets you on the bus.
Come on. Let's go."
Here's some more news
about the president.
I saw that Trump is doing hi
first interview with Telemundo
It will air tomorrow night
It'll be a little different.
For example,
ABC's interview is called
"president Trump: 30 hours."
This one is called
"El Presidente Loco."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Trump is sitting down with
Telemundo,
and it's going to be awkward
when the reporter says
"iBuenos días!"
and Trump's like,
[ As Trump ] Are you related
to Cameron Diaz?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Of course
a lot of people are surprise
that Trump would get togethe
with a Spanish-speaking channel,
but the president was like,
"If Katy Perry and Taylor Swif
can make up, so can we."
I mean, come on. There is hope
There's hope.
Have you guys hear about this?
I saw this hashtag this week
that's been trending all wee
called #SixWordHorror.
People try to tell a horro
story using only six words
Just six words to tell
the scariest situation
they can think of.
Some political figures
were doing it, too.
Check this out.
Sarah Huckabee Sanders wrote
"I have to remain
Press Secretary.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-It's scary stuff.
Bernie Sanders wrote,
"Soup of the day, sold out."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-[ As Sanders ]
Even the chicken vegetable
Oh, my!
[ Normal voice ]
Joe Biden wrote,
"People forget I'm friends
with Barack."
No one's forgetting that.
And finally, Donald Trump wrote,
"O.J. has more followers
than me."
You know? Not happening.
Just scary stories.
-Horror. They're scary.
-Scary stuff.
Finally, you guys, get this --
I saw that Costco is now selling
a giant two-pound doughnut
Look at this thing.
[ Audience cheering ]
There's actually
a name for that.
It is called a cake.
We have a great show tonight
Give it up for The Roots!